thank you for joining us i'm john
langler we start with another pedestrian
hit and killed on our streets
this time the vehicle involved a small
rtc bus
this is happening right now at eastern
end sahara which is where we find bianca
holman live with more on what took place
bianca good afternoon
this is a very busy intersection lots of
pedestrians those familiar with the area
know that valley high school
right down the street so this is what we
know so far about the incident
there was a woman elderly woman in the
crosswalk
walking north on eastern and she was hit
by the rtc bus turning right onto his
sahara
from eastern this crash happened around
9 30 this morning the vehicle involved
is this small rtc bus
the elderly woman was taken to sunrise
trauma but unfortunately passed away
for the traffic intersection cycle when
the lights green on eastern those
crossing north or south
also have the light allowing those folks
to walk across
it's unclear who's at fault right now
but police will continue to investigate
obviously they were actually next to
each other if you consider the bus was
also going northbound to go
eastbound onto sahara so there is a
possibility that
the bus had obstructions that the bus
driver could not see
the pedestrian that was standing there
at the crosswalk waiting to cross but we
won't know all that until
actually the video that we've got
there's a ton of video here so we should
be able to get some decent video of the
collision
a matter of fact the intersection has
been closed lots of people were turned
away
redirected to go around we're also told
rtc will conduct their own
investigation with the driver and also
we're told that this
intersection is due to open in about an
hour reporting bianca holmen 8 news now
bianca thank you very much